نعم التطورات مستمره حقيقه منذ ساعات
الصباح الاولى والغارات الاسرائيليه لم
تتوقف على المحافظه الوسطى من قطاع غزه
حيث قبل قليل فقط شرق مخيم البريج وسط
قطاع غزه اغارت الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه بعده صواريخ على مربعا سكنيا
ولكن حسب الاتصالات الاوليه مع شهود عيان
ومع مواطنين في تلك المنطقه يتحدثون بان
المنطقه مخلاه من المواطنين ولا اصابات
وصلت هنا الى مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير
البل ولكن الغارات كانت غارات قويه
والانفجارات كانت مرتفعه للغايه وسمعت في
ارجاء المحافظه الوسطى بشكل كامل اما في
منطقه المصدر شرق دير البلح تعرضت هذه
المنطقه قبل اقل من نصف ساعه من الان الى
عدد كبير من قذائف المدفعيه التي ما زالت
تتساقط على هذه المنطقه حتى هذه اللحظات
اما غرب مخيم النصيرات وسط القطاع كانت
هناك غارات اسرائيليه بالقرب من مدارس
تتبع للاونروا بداخلها عدد من النازحين
الفلسطينيين الذين جاؤوا خلال الساعات
الماضيه من مدينه غزه بعد ان اجبر الجيش
الاسرائيلي عدد كبير من المواطنين يقارب
من ال 700 مواطن على الخروج من اربع مدارس
رئيسيه غرب مدينه غزه ووصلوا الى المحافظه
الوسطى مشيا على الاقدام من مدينه غزه عبر
الطريق الساحل طريق الرشيد بطبيعه الحال
وصلوا المواطنون هنا ولكن الغارات
الاسرائيليه كانت قريبه من هذه المدارس
الذي يعني جاؤوا اليها المواطنين ليحتموا
بداخلها جراء الغارات الاسرائيليه والتعب
الكبير الذي الذ بات واضحا على وجوههم
خلال السير من الطريق الساحلي وصولا الى
المحافظه الوسطى كما ذكرت كما اجبرهم
الجيش الاسرائيلي الى الخروج من هذه
المدارس اما هنا في مستشفى شهداء الاقصى
وصل عدد من الاصابات صباح هذا اليوم جراء
اطلاق قذائف مدفعيه شرق مخيم المغازي
للاجئين الفلسطينيين التي ما زالت القوات
الاسرائيليه تواصل قصفها باتجاه هذا
المخيم الذي خلال الايام السابقه تراجعت
القوات البريه التي كانت متوغل في هذا
المخيم باتجاه الاطراف الشرقيه من مخيم
المغازي وهذا الامر ما احدث وتبين الدمار
الكبير الذي لحق بمخيم المغازي والمخيمات
المحافظه الوسطى بشكل عام